experts on energy including oil and gas
say that solar and wind are the energy
of the future but while consumers wait
for the future expansion of alternative
energy the fossil fuel industry is
pushing for natural gas to be what it
calls a bridge to that future in the
u.s. drillers are busily tapping gas as
well as oil from underground rocks known
as shale in a process called hydraulic
fracturing more commonly known as
fracking but not everyone is convinced
the transitional fossil fuel is all it's
cracked up to be
despite its benefits fracking remains
unpopular in many parts of the world
especially among climate activists and
locals most affected by the process and
with plummeting oil prices triggered by
the coronavirus and Saudi Arabia's
standoff with Russia the financial
viability of shale is in jeopardy
fracking is a fairly new process of
natural gas extraction first
commercially introduced in 1949 it
involves forcing water mitts with sand
and chemicals into a well to create
fissures in shale rock so oil and gas
trapped inside can escape advances in
the 1980s in a technique called
horizontal drilling opened up access to
thin layers of shale even deeper
underground
over the past decade US oil and gas
output has searched 57% mostly due to
shale rich areas such as the Permian
Basin which stretches from Texas to New
Mexico
America's recent energy dominance was
meant to undercut OPEX ability to
manipulate the market but in March of
2020 Russia triggered an oil war with
Saudi Arabia cratering global prices the
shale industry which has higher
production cost in places like Saudi
Arabia and Russia and relies heavily on
debt finance was hit the hardest
major shale operations like whiting
petroleum Corp and Diamondback all but
promised major job cuts and production
halt after shares dropped 40 to 45
percent respectively
adding to the recent woes fracking
remains highly controversial it has
become a huge target for climate
activists who point to its damaging
effects on the environment a handful of
European countries have effectively
banned the practice due to its
environmental impacts opponents cite an
enormous amount of water needed in
fracking depending on the shale deposits
it can take anywhere between 1.5 and 16
million gallons to frack a well large
though those numbers seem a study by
Duke University calculated that the
water used in fracking makes up less
than 1% of total industrial water used
nationwide there's also evidence that
fracking and more commonly the pumping
of resulting wastewater into wells
triggers earthquakes they've mostly been
small but one in 2016 and the oil-rich
state of Oklahoma shook homes and
buildings across the state for almost a
minute and measured five point eight on
the Richter scale earthquake
tremors in China's shale hub in Sichuan
province killed two people and damaged
11,000 homes in February of 2019 there's
no easy answer on fracking no one can
deny that shale has benefited the US
economically but now there are very real
concerns about whether the fracking
revolution is coming to a close
defenders who continue to point to big
picture benefits like job creation and
energy independence are now staring down
the barrel of job cuts scale backs and
bankruptcies fracking opponents point to
the climate warming methane and natural
gas that sometimes escapes into the
atmosphere before it gets burned and
reject industry claims that shale is a
bridge fuel to a renewable future now
faced with an increasingly hostile
economic environment in addition to
long-standing opposition from
environmental groups the US shale
industry faces a very uncertain future
Oh
you